well if you've not been uh paying
attention to the news for the last um 20
or so hours closer to 24 now uh vladimir
putin's russia has started an invasion
of ukraine and this is
i mean listen you know at a certain
point
when you see 190 000 troops massing at
the border
and you understand that it really is
starting to not make sense merely as a
posturing exercise what putin is doing
you start to consider this might be the
precursor to some kind of an invasion
and almost exactly as predicted by many
vladimir putin creating a pretext for
that invasion using all sorts of fluffy
language like peacekeeping to justify
that invasion
doing it slowly
but a slow invasion is still an invasion
and that's what we have going on stock
markets around the world
very rattled in anticipation of what may
be very erratic energy prices further
supply chain delays and all of the
economic sequelae we we will talk about
once we get a sense of what the scope of
this is going to be but for the time
being
sort of following the georgia playbook
that's not atlanta georgia where
marjorie taylor green is from i'm
talking about the country of georgia and
um
possibly all of this meant to goad
ukraine
into an overreaction to provide an even
bigger pretext for a larger scale
conflict so let's kind of talk through
what is going on
yesterday uh okay so let me back up even
there are
what we might call
separatists in ukraine separatists
meaning
they don't want to be part of ukraine
they want to be part of russia okay
two of the regions in which there are
such separatists are regions and i i'm
going to do my best with the
pronunciation here
the donetsk region
and the luhansk region these are on east
eastern ukraine you can pull it up on
google maps and and sort of take a look
at what where these are so what vladimir
putin did early yesterday or actually it
was early in the u.s it was already kind
of in the afternoon in russia and
ukraine is
recognize those uh as um regions as as
uh legitimized legitimately recognize
those areas as independent so putin is
saying okay it's part of ukraine
donetsk is part of ukraine luhansk is
part of ukraine but there are
separatists there who quote really are
russian they speak the language they
want to be part of russia so we're going
to say those are independent regions not
ukrainian regions now if you're ukraine
you say wait hold on
it's it's part of the country it's
ukraine but putin says no those are
those are independent regions
he then hours later after some mild
sanctions were imposed by the eu and the
united states on uh on putin for doing
this hours later and really the
sanctions were imposed on those regions
rather than on what we might consider
russia proper putin says hey
are the separatists in those quote
independent areas that i've recognized
they are going they're under attack so
we need to go in and send in
peacekeeping forces into that area it's
the putin playbook hook line and sinker
and there shouldn't really be anything
surprising about it
this is what he was signaling for a long
time this is what various foreign policy
analysts and experts were saying could
could be done for a long time some kind
of pretext to then send in troops but
you know they call them peacekeeping but
it doesn't matter how slow it is it
doesn't matter if you say you're there
to keep the peace it is still
fundamentally
an invasion we have video
um where you see
um
tanks rolling down the road this was
yesterday shortly after this
announcement was made
and of course the question now is to
what degree is this going to escalate or
grow now there are some people who we'll
talk about in a little bit
who are really going out of their way to
sort of defend and normalize what russia
is doing and you can be against american
involvement and be against war and be
against violence the way that i am
and still recognize that this is a
classic russian playbook that this is an
invasion that russia has no right to
send tanks uh where they are sending
tanks into the donetsk and luhansk
regions and just imagine a similar
situation with mexico or quebec these
are not perfect analogies but imagine
that mexico said hey you know what
um there are people in texas and arizona
they look like us
and they speak spanish our language and
they would prefer
to be part of mexico
rather than the united states in texas
or arizona so we are recognizing these
enclaves of mexican-americans as mexico
they are independent as far as mexico is
concerned well in the u.s we would say
yeah but that's the united states and i
mean they could go to mexico you're not
stopping if you want to welcome them
they could go and then mexico says well
listen on the basis of the independence
of these uh separatists we're gonna send
some peacekeeping troops in come on guys
nobody would go for it think of quebec
another analogy these are not perfect
analogies but they they are useful in
thinking about this
in quebec there is a separate this
movement imagine that that separatist
movement in quebec canada said well we
don't want to be our own country
we want to be part of the united states
would would the u.s have any right to
say hey those quebec separatists we
think of them as independent because
they really want to be part of us oh
they need us to help keep them safe
we're going to send some tanks there
give me a break guys it's absolutely
absurd now we have video from the eu
foreign policy chief joseph burrell
who is still kind of hedging a little
bit as to the terms that are being used
let's take a listen
well the russian troops has entered in
donbass
we consider donbass part of ukraine
so certainly the russian troops entered
into the donbas ukrainian
i wouldn't say that a fully fledged
invasion
but russian troops are on the ukrainian
side yeah they've invaded one part of
russia is what we i'm sorry one part of
ukraine
um the idea
maybe just do this and then back off
we don't know and again i hope that
people recognize that all along i've
said
we can make assessments based on the
signals but we don't really know what
putin plans to do this could just be one
tiny step a day so there's never any one
day where it's like wow look at what
happened and then they moved towards
kiev
um
it's just it's not completely clear
um
we are also going to have to consider
what putin's greater ideology here is
and it's sort of like the idea of
pointing back to the former ussr
ukraine is really important in putin's
mind in kind of recreating that and
we'll talk about that on the bonus show
today but also in terms of tactics this
is really kind of back to like an old
war concept which is can you just change
your country's borders by force since
world war ii
and since the codification
in international law that prohibits the
threat or use of force against
territorial integrity or political
independence we've seen few attempts to
just change your country's border by
force in this degree now you could say
well you know there's a bunch of areas
of the border
in india where there are constant
disputes and small skirmishes and little
bits of land taken and given back and it
is changing the border in a way by force
in in major ways there have really only
been four attempts since world war ii
north korea in 1950 trying to conquer
south korea
north vietnam successfully conquering
south vietnam in 75
indonesia uh annexing t more less than
75 and that very short very short-lived
iraqi annexation of kuwait in 1990
before it was liberated in what we call
the first gulf war so
this is not super common since world war
ii it will be important not only to
watch what happens in russia but also to
watch china's behavior and ambitions on
the basis of what happens with russia
ukraine because if russia gets away with
this
china's interest in similar action with
taiwan may increase so a lot at play
here and in the immediate it's going to
remain extraordinarily chaotic
one of our sponsors is nebia who's
introducing their newest shower head the
nebia by moan cuatro
it was designed by former nasa engineers
who spent years researching how to save
water quattro is the world's best high
pressure water saving showerhead
starting at just 119
and quattro uses 40 to 50 percent less
water than traditional shower heads
helping the planet helping your wallet
still giving you the high pressure water
stream you love with four different
spray modes literally takes one to two
minutes to install easy as screwing in a
light bulb i love it i have the rain
shower version i've been using nebia
shower heads for a while now i love
saving the water and i love the high
pressure spray it's really the best of
both worlds nebia the maker of quattro
also offers sustainable bathroom
accessories i have the soft gray bath
mat and the nebia double shelf the
quattro showerhead is just 119 but nebia
is giving you ten percent off when you
go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video